talk about these high schoolers all
doing drugs and banging each other oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah euphoria why is
everyone talking about this i've never
seen this show i just started watching
it like two weeks ago explain this show
to me all right so the show centers
around zendaya's character she's great
by the way she's great great in
spider-man she's great in dune she's
just awesome
she's very she's very funny and good at
being funny in dramatic moments yeah
good at the drama i saw that movie on
netflix malcolm and marie and i wasn't
that impressed but spider-man she's
great in this show she's great and she's
just like she i think she low-key kind
of like this generation is like beyonce
we're like this is the girl that
everything she does she knocks it out
the [ __ ] part
that's a good take so this show i wasn't
it was too [ __ ] wild for me and it
makes me sad to watch but it centers
around this girl yeah for sure it
centers around this girl high school
girl who has a drug addiction mental
health issues drug addiction loves
taking drugs and she navigates her life
in high school around all these other
high schoolers who have their own [ __ ]
going on so like she falls in love with
a girl who's trans got the surgery mad
young i think born as a boy now as a
girl they have a relationship smash
they yeah i'm sure they [ __ ] they
don't show it but in the [ __ ] first
episode when the opening scenes that
girl gets [ __ ] by a dude who is a
grown man with kids married this is a
crime that you watch happen
on who who committed the guy the
grown-ass man [ __ ] that trans girl she
was like 16 years old but did the trans
girl say this yeah she signed up she
wanted it she they met up it was in a
hotel room but said that she was trans
i think he knew they they make it pretty
clear he knows okay yeah that's wild
wild
mad drug use like the [ __ ] uh
there's like the good looking white kid
but he's got his own issues i think they
do a great job of telling the story and
somehow painting every figure no matter
how shitty they are in a somewhat at
least somewhat empathetic light like
normally you watch a show like this the
straight white guy is just a piece of
[ __ ] through and through and he's the
constant villain and you have no room
for empathy for this guy they give you a
little room for empathy for this guy
you're like oh this guy dealing with
some [ __ ] too i guess yeah he's a
[ __ ] great actor too that guy is
great full-ass australian you can't tell
at all he has an accent and when he was
talking about some of the character [ __ ]
i was like oh this is why some actors
deserve my respect some because he found
the place the way he's talking about it
he's like yo he found the empathy for
this guy because you got to play a
[ __ ] monster yeah and if we can have
a shred of empathy then you can play him
more three-dimensional yeah and this is
to your point hbo kill scripted series
[ __ ] they do man and just the best this
show is everything that is good about
hbo in one show it is raw as [ __ ] is it
weird beautiful teenager
that's what makes me sad why is it not
because this [ __ ] is going on it's so
depicted of real life so is a lot of
stuff and we don't have to watch us no
but all these people are of age they're
not actual teenagers right they're just
playing it right so it's like you know
that so you can feel you don't feel icky
about it i didn't watch kids so i don't
i usually stay away from that kind of
[ __ ]
yeah this one i my wife was watching so
i sat down with kids
is this a show it was a movie it was a
movie about a bunch of [ __ ] up keys in
new york right it's basically like rent
the straight version
yeah like you know teenagers yeah
everybody gets aids like that's
basically what happens
oh it's like skins or some [ __ ] yeah
it's like uh this is uh skins is like i
think the british version but this was a
really popular it took place basically
like in my neighborhood like i knew i
saw like these kids like skateboarding
and that kind of [ __ ] and like um it was
it was just like really [ __ ]
i mean it was dark it was like really
dark look at like teen sexuality and
drug use and like partying
this is dark dude there are multiple
scenes rosario dawson got her uh start
in that part i think she was also in
rent the movie yeah she was yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they came
one yeah but it was it's a really
fascinating like movie like watch it
it's it's [ __ ] up that's how i feel
about this it's [ __ ] but it is well
done it's like undeniably a well-done
show
and uh i think one you guys asked does
it scare you to have kids and it truly
does yeah and not just because
the kids are so wild in that like old
sense of like oh the world is going to
hell yeah it really let me know how out
of touch i am with kids
like i'm 37 i'm not crazy old but i'm so
[ __ ] out of touch with these 17 year
olds yeah like gender seems kind of
fluid sexuality definitely seems fluid
drug use is just a casual thing like
just the way you guys see the race is
truly not a factor and not in a
heavy-handed corny way yep
i mean that's good yeah it's cool they
don't see race as an issue at all super
p
yeah it's just extremely it's wow yeah
yeah it's like super p like that's like
mad p
but like and then i thought about like
in 20 years when these when i have kids
talking about the metaverse and they're
just living in this [ __ ] thing i'm
gonna look at you and be like i have no
idea how to help you i have no idea how
to guide you through whatever the [ __ ]
this is i'm so out of touch
and it's only gonna
increase exponentially how out of touch
i am every year when i have kids who are
16 17 trying to navigate teenage years
i'm gonna be like dog i got no clue what
you're even saying to me
[ __ ]
that's overwhelming it is tough
i'm watching that moving to a ranch
you